Je fais des mouvements rapides pour capter votre attention
pour la vingt-troisième vidéo du calendrier de l'Avent et là j'ai une question : qu'est-ce qui
comporte 140 plans de sauvetage pour vous sauver à hauteur d'une minute, de 5 minutes ou de dix minutes
mais qui coûte moins de 3 euros ?
C'est le cadeau que je vous présente aujourd'hui ce 23 décembre,
je fais des mouvements avec la main pour avoir l'air plus intéressant.
Je fais mon petit intéressant aujourd'hui !
"Petits jeux pour tuer le temps" de Laurent Gaulet, qui a écrit plein plein de livres en humour,
qui a créé plein plein plein plein plein plein de jeux.
Je sais que ce mec a vendu plus de deux millions d'exemplaires de tous les produits qu'il a fait,
et ça c'est une vraie réussite.
Je ne m'en suis pas encore beaucoup servi,  je ne l'ai eu que récemment.
Je cherchais en fait un vrai livre, un peu rigolo et pas cher pour la
dernière vidéo. Oui parce que petit spoil c'est la dernière vidéo où je vous présente quelque chose.
Demain si vous venez sur la chaîne, je vous le dis sincèrement,
je vous propose quelque chose de oufissime.
Mais ça c'est demain c'est à 6H du matin.
Voilà comme ça vous le savez. "Petit jeu pour tuer le temps". Comme son nom l'indique, à l'intérieur il y a des jeux qui
durent une minute, des jeux qui durent 5 minutes, des jeux qui durent 10 minutes et des jeux à faire à plusieurs.
C'est le concept du livre et le concept est respecté à 100%. Du style, je prends un jeu d'une minute pour voir. C'est un tue-le-temps :
Votre bâillement est-il communicatif ? Vérifiez le en
essayant de faire bâiller le maximum de personnes en un minimum de temps. Nombre de personnes ; durée, et tu notes ça à chaque fois.
C'est un petit jeu débile. Un petit casse tête, un petit gribouillage,
un petit google. Alors oui, je suis en train de me dire en le feuilletant ça me rappelle le livre de Squeezie.
Puisque je l'ai feuilleté l'autre jour, le livre de Squeezie. Y a un peu de ça c'est vrai, il y a
un point commun avec le livre de Squeezie. Des jeux de cinq minutes, donc là on
commence à attaquer du labyrinthe sérieux. On a un jeu de calcul-tout, des casse têtes un petit peu plus coriaces.
Les jeux de dix minutes,
on retrouve encore les principes des passe temps, des calculs-tout. C'est toujours les mêmes jeux mais un peu plus complexifiés.
Des jeux de dix minutes on passe une étape par exemple énigme.
Mais vous, si vous suivez la chaîne, j'ai déjà posé une énigme comme ça dans les énigmes de 2016.
Avant-hier Lucas avait 13 ans, l'année prochaine il en aura 16. Comment est-ce possible ?
Allez ceux qui savent, ne le dites pas tout de suite si vous avez déjà vu ça sur ma chaîne il y a un an. Mais je
vous repose la question les autres : Avant-hier Lucas avait 13 ans, l'année prochaine il en aura 16. Comment est ce possible ?
Loïc, derrière la caméra, est-ce que tu as une idée de comment c'est possible ?
Oui vraiment ?
Ah, c'est pas mal. Parce que tu l'as vu sur la chaîne ou là tu as une idée ?
[rires]
Il a aucune idée ! Je vous laisse chercher ça.
La réponse est située dans son anniversaire. Voilà c'est l'indice : la réponse est située dans son anniversaire. Et après les jeux à plusieurs,
on a soit des petites batailles navales,
soit des idées de jeu avec des règles simples où tu peux jouer sans rien,
des variantes du pendu, du ni oui ni non, du "le compte est bon", du "le mot le plus long" ...
Voilà je trouve que c'est le petit livre qu'on aime bien.
Franchement c'est une bonne idée. Bravo Laurent Galet ! Je t'applaudis avec mes deux mains, parce qu'avec une seule main on n'aurait pas le son.
Quant à vous, je vous like. Si vous voulez faire la même chose, c'est avec plaisir. Le lien est dans la description
avec mon lien pour le spectacle de l'Olympia juste au dessus, c'est une bonne idée de cadeau de dernière minute.
Je vous invite à vous abonner si c'est pas encore fait, d'être gentil avec vos proches si c'est pas encore fait et rendez vous demain
pour la dernière vidéo du mois décembre et l'annonce de, mon petit bonhomme ça devrait te plaire,
vraiment soit leur rendez-vous à 6H.
Ciao !  Quand est-ce que ca s'arrête cette vidéo ? On ne sait pas je le sais pas moi même et
personne ne sait. Est-ce qu'on sera un jour ? Je vous êtes encore là ? Stop !
[musique]